[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here fresh new
graphics and welcome to 2018 and we have
a lot of plans for this year as i'm sure
you can imagine and notice i keep saying
we because this actually gradually
started to turn more into a bit of a
team effort at this point as you know it
used to just be me my camera maybe my
computer and not a whole lot but as you
start to get more hands you realize the
benefits of being able to do more things
so you know third person shots moving
shots all kinds of fun angles basically
capturing things and experiences that i
ordinarily couldn't if i was the one
already focusing on the camera work so
this changes things a bit makes it a
little bit more dynamic but in a good
way so yeah bottom line we're going to
be expanding on that again for this year
and i think you'll notice the difference
it makes to the videos
and it'll help us make bigger and better
things and also more often in fact in
2017 i didn't tell you guys this but one
of the goals i had
was to make 100 videos to get a hundred
projects fully complete we ended up at
95 so like i got pretty close but i
think this year in 2018 there's no doubt
we'll have a hundred videos for you in
2017 we also made the casey neistat
studio tour as episode one of a new
series and then we were planning out
episode number two and we're getting all
hyped up and we hung out with dead mouse
in his newly built studio and then linus
made his video which was
basically the same as we were so we're
that's cool we're back to working on
that we got the dope tech series going
that is a fun one that's going to
continue of course and we also shot some
car videos that will never see the light
of day in their completion took a couple
days on them did a lot of shooting and
learned a lot but then later we did make
a car video that did see the light of
day the tesla project love day video
which also happened to win the contest
and now let's just say there will
definitely be some car videos in 2018
that do see the light of day that's a
guarantee we got a pretty good playlist
name for it too something else we
dabbled with in 2017 was the whole idea
of custom merch you know a limited
edition design here and there and that's
fun but i think in 2018
that beast will be entirely different
i don't want to give away too much but i
think you get the idea so in 2017 the
channel passed 5 million subscribers
which is incredible and also rolled past
800 million total video views and of the
95 videos uploaded in 2017 they were
watched about
266 million times in total which
multiplies out to 1.1 billion total
minutes of watch time
geez that's a lot of time but look in
2018 what we really have to look forward
to is all this new tech that's coming
out the new mac pro allegedly apple's
coming out with that this year i've
gotten non-stop questions about the red
hydrogen one that's a big one
um and there's going to be mysteries of
course too maybe an 8k tv or beyond
electric cars foldable phones there's
going to be surprises but i'm going to
do my best to show it all to you
literally my favorite thing to do is
talk about tech and experience it and
use it and i don't thank you guys enough
for this but i am super fortunate to be
in a position where i can not only
experience some bleeding edge tech and
amazing stuff all the time but then i
can also turn around and share it with
you guys i literally one of my favorite
moments of last year was when i
interviewed
at the end of my google i o video i
interviewed sundar pachai the ceo of
google
and that was fun obviously kind of an
on-the-spot thing but that wasn't even
my idea that was google's idea that they
came to me with so the fact that
companies at this point are reaching out
uh shows that there's a lot of doors
open and i just have to step through
them to try to share that experience
with you guys a lot of it's going to
feel outside of my comfort zone and i
know that and that's sort of like a
general new year's resolution to do that
as well but that's what makes us better
either way bottom line welcome to 2018
uh i hope every video i upload this year
is better than every video from last
year and from all the previous years and
i think that's definitely possible
but other than that
thanks for watching talk to you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]